cloud并没有推荐那些花哨的写作模式
而是强调了一个看起来没那么聪明的角色
验证行子agent
为什么验证agent是最稳的拆分点
我们先看它的典型模式
这里有两个角色
一个是主agent
他负责真正干活写代码生成内容
他拥有完整的上下文
理解为什么要这么做
另一个就是验证agent
他完全不关心过程
他不需要理解这个结果是怎么来的
他只需要回答一个问题
结果是否满足预先定义的标准
讲到这里
细心的观众可能会有一个巨大的疑问
等一下你在上一期视频不是刚说过
把测试拆分出去是错误的传声筒架构吗
为什么今天又说拆分验证是最安全的
这难道不矛盾吗
这个问题的答案正是多agent设计的精髓所在
请大家注意
第二期我们反对的是拆分编写测试
而今天我们推荐的是拆分执行验证
这两者有什么区别
编写测试是白盒任务
要写出好的测试代码
A证必须理解业务逻辑
理解代码结构
理解开发者为什么要这么实现
这就需要大量的上下文
如果强行拆分测试agent就会变成瞎子
必须不断问开发agent
这就掉进了传声筒陷阱
但在执行验证时是黑盒任务验证
A证不需要知道代码是怎么写的
也不需要知道这行代码为什么用for循环
他只需要拿到产物
对照标准机械的执行检查
打个比方
写测试就像学生写作文
必须自己构思
不能让别人替你写
这叫上下文内句执行验证
就像老师判卷子
老师根本不在乎你写作时的心理活动
只看你字数够不够
有没有跑题
这种标准客观独立的工作最适合拆分给子agent
所以验证任务天然符合我们第二期讲的
以上下文为中心的分解原则
它是上下缘最干净的一类工作
理解了这个逻辑
你就打开了思路
验证agent不仅仅能用来测代码
任何标准明确
不需要理解过程的工作都能交给他
比如合规检查主agent写合同
验证agent拿着公司法务手册去核对
他不用懂法律逻辑
只看条款在不在
比如事实核查主agent写文章
验证agent专门去搜google
验证每一个数据的真实性
比如格式校验
专门检查输出的JSON字段
对不对
他是你系统中成本最低但收益最高的守门员
但是即使是这么安全的拆分起点
实战中也有一个巨大陷阱
过早胜利
问题cloud发现验证子agent往往有偷懒的倾向
因为LLM倾向于顺从用户
想尽快结束对话
经常出现的情况是
验证者只跑了一两个最简单的测试
发现通过了就立刻宣布大功告成
但这其实是假象
一旦上线遇到复杂边界情况
系统就会崩溃
怎么防止A阵偷懒
官方给出了四条防偷懒铁律
建议大家直接写进system prompt
第一具体标准不要说确保能运行
要说运行完整的测试套件
并报告所有的失败项
第二全面检查
强制要求覆盖边界情况
比如空值超长文本
第三负向测试
你要指令验证者
试着输入一些会导致失败的数据
并确认系统真的报错了
如果无论输入什么
他都说成功
说明测试是假的
第四显示指令使用强祈使句
比如你必须运行完所有测试
才能标记为通过
讲到这里
Building multi agent systems
When and how to use them
系列就正式结束了
最后让我们回到原点
cloud在结尾给出了落地检查清单
在你动手写代码前
请再一次问自己这三个问题
第一真的有物理限制吗
单体能解决的
坚持用单体
第二是按上下文拆分的吗
拆分边界是基于知识需求还是盲目模仿流水线
第三有清晰的验证点吗
你能否定义出明确标准
让子agent进行黑盒验证
如果用一句话总结整篇文章
那就是从单体开始
只在真实约束出现时引入多agent
而多agent最稳的拆分起点是验证子agent
而不是更复杂的思考agent好了
这个系列就到这里
这里是慢学AI
我们下期再见